In this video I want to
he explains
potassium-sodium pump.
As the name suggests, it pumps
sodium and potassium, but
in different directions.
This is a pump scheme,
this is my drawing, my version of
potassium-sodium pump.
It is transmembrane
protein complex.
In an inactive state
it is open to the inside of the cage
and has affinity for sodium ions.
Here you see
three sodium ions,
depicted in blue.
They will connect to the pump.
Once they do
the pump will want to be
phosphorylated by ATP.
We see this here.
This is the ATP,
adenosine triphosphate.
When the pump is phosphorylated,
energy is released,
which allows change in conformation (structure)
of the protein that builds the pump.
The new conformation of the protein
will be open from above,
to the outside and closed to the interior of the cell.
She will not be there anymore
affinity for sodium ions,
but to potassium ions.
This is very interesting.
The release of energy, the change in conformation,
that these proteins
are molecular machines,
remarkable molecular machines.
Once this happens,
once the conformation of the protein has changed,
sodium ions will be
separated outside the cage.
Then we will have potassium ions,
which will be connected to the outside of the pump.
When this happened,
there will be a conformational change.
The pump will be
dephosphorylated
and will return to
its initial conformation.
This initial conformation.
When the pump stops affinity to
potassium ions,
they will be released
and we will return
to the initial phase.
This is remarkable!
To carry out this transport is
uses ATP, uses energy, hence it is active transport.
It takes energy to get it done.
I will write it.
This is active,
this is an active transport.
We talk about it
here.
Pumping ions,
using ATP. We can pump
three sodium ions out,
I'll write it down.
Three sodium ions out.
In this process, we pump and
two potassium ions inside.
Pumping two potassium
ion inside the cell.
Now you can say,
"Well, both sodium and potassium ions have a positive charge,
but pumping three sodium ions out
and two potassium inwards.
This should make the outside
more positive than the inside of the cell. "
Actually it is.
But not just the potassium-sodium pump is responsible for this fact.
It plays only a partial role
for the electrical potential difference
between the inner
and the outside of the membrane.
What is very important for the potential
are the protein channels,
which allow potassium ions
to move in the direction of
their concentration gradient.
Think about what's going on
before we talk
for these protein channels.
What is the concentration gradient of sodium
due to the work of a potassium-sodium pump?
The concentration of sodium from the outside
is higher,
and its concentration in the cell
is smaller.
This is the concentration gradient of sodium.
What is the concentration gradient of potassium?
Potassium is pumped from the outside into the interior
of the cage.
So potassium has a reverse concentration gradient.
He has a high concentration inside
and low concentration outside the cell.
If we let the potassium pass through the membrane,
are we talking about that in other videos,
the ions can not simply pass
through the membrane,
if their transport is not relieved in any way.
The membrane is not permeable to things like ions,
such as sodium and potassium ions.
But if we have protein channels here,
who run potassium
to come out, what will happen?
You can give one of the two answers.
1. Can you say -
things are transported by diffusion in the direction
of their concentration gradient,
because we have more
potassium ions down here,
there is a larger one
probability
to move from that to that country,
than to this one.
We will have a net leakage of potassium from the cell.
2. But you can say that
the first answer is valid if we are interested
only by the concentration gradient.
What will happen if we look at the charge?
We say the inside of the cage
will be less positive,
and on the outside of the membrane medium
will be more positive,
because
has a larger total ion charge,
the appearance will be more positive.
The same charges are required
to move away from one another.
Positive ions
want to move on
more negative places.
These potassium ions
are positively charged,
why would they want to go from
less positive in a more positive place?
If you guessed any of these two things,
the explanation with the concentration gradient
or the difference in electrical potential,
you are right in both cases.
These two forces are balanced.
Concentration gradient
will allow some of the
potassium ions leave the cell,
but there is no potassium concentration
to align on both sides of the membrane
because of the difference in electric potential.
The exterior is more positive,
the interior is less positive.
When the potassium ions leave the cell,
they move in the opposite direction
to the one who wants their charge.
They move in the direction of the concentration gradient,
but at some point this will be balanced.
Pumping
sodium ions out
in a higher ratio
in comparison to that of the potassium ions pumped into the cell,
is released
yet positive charge outside the cage.
The so-called
membrane potential of rest.
It is extremely important for all cells,
but especially for nerve cells
or neurons.
They use it
2/3 of its energy,
to establish and preserve
membrane potential of rest.
As we will see in the neuron video,
this is because they constantly use this potential,
to transmit signals along the neuron.
But the membrane potential of rest
is less positive here and more positive here.
If you measure that
in comparison,
this difference (depending on
of the measurement)
will be about -70 mV (millivolt).
I've also seen measurements that indicate -60 or -80 mV.
-70 mV.
This potential is key to neurons
and for all other cells.
But the function of the potassium-sodium pump
is not the only establishment of
membrane potential of rest.
Higher sodium concentration
outside the cage can be used
and in various forms of active transport.
When sodium ions move in the direction of their concentration gradient,
is possible
to ship things like glucose molecules.
In fact, these biological systems
are much more complex,
than we often portray them in our videos.
But I want you to appreciate that
and know how important it is
potassium-sodium pump.
It was known in the 1950s,
but only in 1997 was awarded the Nobel Prize
for its discovery
and to explore the mechanisms,
on which he works.